à ce sujet un peu inquiétant ce soir les
avions ligne seront ils plus
susceptibles d'être détournés avec de
l'équipement informatique
la question est revenue récemment dans
l'actualité à cause d'événements qui
heureusement ne sont pas tragique mais
pour combien de temps matthieu dugal bon
soir en soir céline inquiétant je me
disais mars que ce un expert en
informatique affirmant un pic compte le
contrôle d'un avion
oui on a appris ça ce rapport du fbi et
dont le magazine world a obtenu copie
s'agit d'un responsable d'une
association de cyber sécurité qui aurait
pris donc le conditionnel est important
le contrôle de boeing 737 dans un vol
chicago syracuse la mer la manière dont
il s'y est pris s'appelle chris brown on
peut le qualifier de pirate éthique donc
on a personne anglais les white hat
c'est à dire c'est des gens qui se
charge d'aller trouver des failles de
sécurité pour alerter les autorités par
la suite gentilly est un gentil pirate
on peut dire comme ça ils auraient pris
le contrôle de l'avion en se branchant
avec un câble ethernet donc le cap dont
on se sert pour avoir du signal internet
sur son ordinateur sous un boîtier de
connexion qu'on retrouve sous les sièges
d'un avion est donc le réussir mon faire
monter l'avion le faire descendre le
faire tourner de gauche à droite
évidemment ce sont ces allégations s'est
pas encore prouvé mais il dit qu'il
aurait réussi à faire une dizaine de
fois depuis 2001 il disait une dizaine
de fois bon évidemment ces allégations
là elles surviennent après une mise en
garde à ses sérieux là d'un organisme de
surveillance américain
oui une agence qui est pas très connus
agence indépendante de surveillance
d'investigation et d'évaluation des
travaux qui sont effectués par le
gouvernement fédéral le government
accountability office
c'est un rapport qui est assez
surprenant parce qu'il dit les pirates
de l'air pourrait avoir accès à des
avions sans même y entrer par
l'extérieur où il ya voir accepte
seulement par leur ordinateur ils sont
assis dans un siège avec les autres
passagers commencent à baisser parce
qu'il faut pas oublier que le federal
aviation administration est en train de
mener un vaste programme de mise à jour
de la gestion du trafic aérien donc ça
s'appelle le next gen ça va coûter 40
milliards de dollars sur 20 ans et donc
ce qu'on veut faire avec ça c'est
changer la gestion du trafic aérien par
le radar pour le remplacer par de la
gestion par des satellites
oui ça certains avantages quand elle a
certes un avantage évidemment pu changer
les plans de vol plus rapidement ou si
ça peut permettre aux passagers
de faire valoir leur droit inaliénable à
mettre à jour leur statut facebook et
donc ça a même quand même des des
problèmes parce qu'avec les routeurs qui
sont utilisés pour aller dans
l'ordinateur de bord de l'avion
ce seraient les mêmes goûteurs qui
serait en fait il serait connectée à des
routeurs qui permettrait de les prendre
et courriels ou bien d'avoir accès au
système de divertissement en vol
sauf qu'il y aurait des pare feu qui
séparaient ces deux routeurs là sauf que
c'est par feu là selon le ga au toujours
ne serait pas étanche complètement il
serait piratables alors c'est là que ça
devient quand même
aucune faille il ya des failles et ses
failles label strut serait encore le
conditionnel est important
éventuellement exploitables par des
pirates
évidemment il faut pas attendre une
tragédie arrive pour s'y mettre mais
quand même ça fait quand même deux
deux alertes quand même assez sérieuse
au cours des derniers mois en regardant
la sécurité aérienne pourrait peut-être
s'y arrêter un peu avant que quelque
chose de plus sérieux
oui tout à fait du tout avec le white
mike est maintenant c'est absolument 36%
les avions turcs sont connectés à
internet
matthieu dugal merci beaucoup de nous
avoir inquiété aujourd'hui mon voyage